Avengers Assemble
[Applause]
[Music]
so hey you know what I realized I
haven't done in a while
ranked the Marvel movies and actually
given that we have no idea when the next
one's gonna be released anymore was
supposed to be originally I think this
month for Black Widow but now who knows
I guess there's no better time than to
rank the ones we've got and given that
we have completed now phases one through
three
I can outrank the entirety of the
Infinity Saga and I am gonna include
spider-man far from home with that
because even though I guess it wasn't
directly part of that's like it was
still counted as part of Phase three so
that's in there in the mix now I don't
think I did this last time I write but I
know at least one time when ranking
these I included the seasons of the TV
shows I'm not doing that this time
because daredevil Iron Fist and Luke
Cage were the only ones I watched every
season of I don't know why I watch both
seasons of iron fist something's wrong
with me anyways I'm restricting it just
to the films this time starting at the
bottom working our way up
number 23 Iron Man 2 now I suppose it's
worth saying before getting into this I
don't think any of these are
horrendously bad even the ones at the
very bottom even this one even Iron Man
2 is just mediocre and a letdown from
what the film that came before it but as
a movie in and of itself it's
inoffensive but there's really nothing
to write home about here the aspects of
Tony Stark get taken up another notch
and it works for his overall character
arc in terms of the progression across
the series but there isn't much else to
recommend here the villains are bland
both of them both the one he has to
fight and the corporate villain I don't
really care for either of them
there's a couple of decent action scenes
but there really is very little that is
memorable at all about this film
aside from possibly the introduction of
Black Widow so moving up another sequel
that huh didn't uh didn't fly too well
number 22 Thor 2 or Thor the dark world
officially because for some of these
they do numbers and others they don't
yeah and this one this one I find
slightly more memorable than Iron Man 2
largely on the back of Loki because he
gets some good stuff but the problem
with this one is it just takes itself
way too seriously it's not to say it's
100% devoid of comic moments it has a
couple including some it like that
really weird times that don't work but
the overall tone is just so dour it's
not fun and the key thing for most of
these movies is they're fun and when
they're not fun and still work it's
because there's a real reason for them
to be something other than just fun Thor
the dark world is dark because they
decided it was gonna be dark also again
very a memorable villain what a waste of
Christopher Eccleston number 21 is
ant-man in the wasp this one basically
rides on the charm of the cast other
than that I just I don't think there's
anything to recommend this like Oh some
boring corporate style villainy because
the actual villain that they're dealing
with for the most part it doesn't make
sense for ghost who is a decent villain
all things considered but it doesn't
make sense for her to have henchmen and
they need someone with henchmen so that
they can't have more action scenes now
the action scenes as presented are
actually pretty well done that's another
point in its favor but it's just a
contrived film the situation's they're
in to get into these action scenes the
way it progresses it's just very lazily
put together number 20
Spider Man far from home I will admit I
may be overly cruel to this one because
of how excite
I was for it it was a villain we'd never
seen in film before I love spider-man
homecoming you'll be seeing that way
higher up on the list than this but it
just didn't click and it's it's
difficult to pin down why in any big
sweeping ways cuz it's just a lot of
little things the pacing is off the
chunks of time devoted to things in the
flow from one story be to the other feel
awkward and jarring and don't flow very
well for me too much time is spent
lingering on the awkward humor and I
felt they did just the right doses of it
before because awkward humor can really
great I mean quickly but they didn't
find that balance with this one I was
just really let down number 19 at this
point we're actually just getting into
the films that I don't even think have
anything that wrong with them I just
don't enjoy them as much
Iron Man 3 I know a lot of people take
issue with the Mandarin twist I don't I
think it's perfectly fine but there are
other things about this that aren't
great the villain again once we do the
twist and reveal the Mandarin which
again that twist I'm with but our actual
villain kind of bland kind of uninvolved
exciting there's some neat ideas there's
some good dialogue there's some good
chemistry but it just it it isn't there
aren't enough strong things building on
each other it's just little pockets of
pretty good number 18 I know for some
people including some friends of mine
this is gonna be the most control and
controversial entry on this list Captain
America the First Avenger I'm sorry I
don't like him very much Steve Rogers
himself he is phenomenal he is perfectly
casting their scene but a couple of
decent supporting terms from Stanley
Tucci and Peggy Carter has done pretty
well but I honestly think she's a little
underdeveloped and a little bit tropi
here but for the most part it's the the
format and the villains the villains let
this down badly Red Skull looks amazing
but is generic as hell and Hydra is
ever ever threatening in this thing they
get knocked back so often they might as
well be Cobra from GI Joe I really don't
find a lot to like that in this aside
from the central performance which was
perfect but it was the only hair it was
really great number 17
The Incredible Hulk the one we all don't
talk about the Edward Norton one it does
the final confrontation I think is the
biggest letdown here the the Hulk
fighting the abomination if it should
have felt more momentous ultimately it's
just pixel smashing pixels but the time
itself doesn't have to be a criticism
because some of the best action scenes
in this franchise involved the Hulk and
his pixel smashing pixels so it can work
but just for some reason it's just a
little undercooked here that said the
performances are good and yet pretty
much across the board and I feel like
this movie actually gets Bruce Banner
pretty well as a character I think
mainly it's the climax were it let sit
down
number 16 ant-man Matt this this was
just fun there's the ones just a nice
fun good time Paul Rudd I'm not like
really on the Paul Rudd Love Train the
way a lot of people seem to be but I do
enjoy him and he's good for this part
the villain again very bland that's a
big issue with with his bottom ranked
ones is lousy villains but Michael
Douglas is is great good mix there's
good chemistry it's a fun supporting
cast the only reason that's not higher
is there isn't a lot of weight to this
and that's not to say you can't have a
lighter fluffier film that ranks higher
it's just it really has to hit my
personal buttons for to boost it up and
there are gonna be things like that hot
hire but this it was just like yeah it
was fun number 15 Thor going back and
revisiting this one I know I used to put
it higher than this but the thing is a
little bit like Captain America the
First Avenger its buoyed by central
performances what this has over Captain
America is whereas Captain America had
one perfect casting
or has several at the bare minimum Loki
and Thor themselves absolutely perfect I
would also argue that Odin is also
perfectly cast so that altogether gives
it a little bit more of a boost than
strong central performance was able to
give to Captain America the First
Avenger aside from that it's it's good
but you can tell this is early Marvel
that they're still getting their feet
under them it's it's pretty big but it's
not as bold as I need to be it's not as
bold as this franchise got later on
number fourteen men Avengers age of
Ultron
this one's really weird because this is
one that is less than the sum of its
parts because many of the individual
scenes interactions I love like some of
its some of my favorite stuff in the MCU
yet somehow when cobbled together into
the finished product of the film they
don't quite mesh you can feel that this
was supposed to be a longer film that
that this got trimmed down cut down and
in ways that you can you can see the
stitches in some of the areas
particularly when it comes to the
integration of Scarlet Witch and
Quicksilver with Ultron I feel like
there was way more there than then we
got in the final version likewise with
Thor but also the stuff we get with hot
guys family I love it I actually really
like Ultron as a villain I think he's
great there's a lot of great scenes bits
the the thing with the hammer and the
way that that's how they all know they
can trust Vichy because he just picks up
that's great but like the pieces just
don't quite fit right number 13 Doctor
Strange so this was one of the last like
straight-up origin stories that Marvel
told and I think by this point they'd
really refined that formula it is an
origin story and it fits the template of
that pretty cleanly but there are little
things that really boost it again part
of its performance is Benedict
Cumberbatch's great to Attila ejiofor is
is good Benedict Wong is terrific and of
course the conclusion like
I don't think these movies make or break
on their climax but a good climax can
really just make the film sit just right
and the Dormammu I've come to bargain oh
that was good
it was real good number 12 guardians of
the galaxy the first one there's a lot
of good here I love the character
dynamics I love how much thought has
been put into this world how imaginative
it is how bright how colourful how much
fun it is again though we've got a very
weak villain and the conclusion I get
what it's doing on paper but it doesn't
quite pull together for me this is still
a lot of fun though but they build on it
better later number 11
is Captain Marvel this one's kind of an
odd one because this is one that I
really love on paper and I like it as an
experience but I kind of like it better
in principle than in reality but in
reality I enjoy it and in principle I
love it what I mean by that is things
like the way it ends the way she just
blasts the bad guy back basically is
he's standing there yelling debate me I
love that I think brie Larson does a
terrific job I think the discovery of
her own past is really well handled I
think it's really fun watching Samuel
Jackson get to be so front and center
and also have a bit of a lighter vibe as
a younger Nick Fury that's really cool
it's just for whatever reason in the
moment I don't like it quite as much as
I feel like I should given how much I
like the component pieces and on paper
what it's doing I don't know it works I
just feel like it should've worked a
little better and number 10 Iron Man the
original the one that started at all
again largely hinging on essential
performance but holy crap what a
performance if you were gonna make one
performance the backbone of your entire
cinematic universe this was a good one
to go with Robert Emms you you're so
good at embodying thoughtfulness you can
see
the wheels turning his head so he's so
perfect working as someone whose
greatest power for all of his tech is
his brain and watching the man work it's
just it's just phenomenal Hey like
there's other good stuff her his uh his
chemistry with pepper is great Happy's a
lot of fun the films actually not too
bad it's it's just good it's just a good
time number nine thor ragnarok yeah
this was the bold feel that thor needed
bold confident cuz the first floor was
it was pretty bold but i didn't quite go
full steam ahead as i wanted to second
one went grim dark and i don't know why
especially because it like didn't even
go whole hog to that but just as a vibe
it didn't work for it here bright fun
colorful yet still carrying a decent
amount of weight in terms of what is
happening to the characters and the
impact of everything going on the
performances are terrific it's got a
great villain we've got Jeff Goldblum
for crying out loud it's not perfect I
actually still really take issue with
how casually the Warriors three were
killed off in this film but it what
works works phenomenally number eight
Avengers infinity war this shouldn't
worked after all the build-up to oh god
what if this guy gets these stones yo
all the planting all the hints of the
stones and Thanos like this shouldn't
worked
Thanos as a villain shouldn't have been
able to pay off all the build-up the
threat of the stone should have been
able to pay off all the build-up all
these characters being juggled this
should not have worked but man it does
and more than that it can hit you in the
fields numerous points what happens to
Gamora that's heartbreaking got Peter ah
right in the fields and just the
devastating place that leaves things it
is very much deliberately pulling a
Empire Strikes Back level gam
with how it chooses to end that's a hard
thing to pull off but it does number
seven the Avengers another thing that
wasn't supposed to work basically a
massive crossover movie yeah we've
established these characters yeah
they're all in the same universe but are
you really gonna throw them all together
in one movie and have it work
you're gonna balance all these big
personalities people who had it headed
their own movies and now you expect them
to share the screen not muscle each
other out how could you possibly expect
that to work oh oh look at that that's
how it's a smart script it's really well
constructed the interactions are key it
never loses sight of the way that the
characters play off each other and
interact with each other and clash with
each other and then ending in a massive
action scene that should be boring by
the time it's done but just is it
because it knows how to uptick in just
the right ways at just the right moment
puny God ah yes
number 6 Avengers end game I'm not sure
I can actually make a substantive
argument as to why endgame is a better
film than infinity war because it might
not be infinity war might be a better
film from a construction narrative and
you know the standard you know objective
measures I just have more fun with
endgame I think maybe it's because
partly I just have more fun in the
rousing triumph of it cuz this is a
triumphant film
it builds so much at the end but it's
also fun along the way and even with the
weight of everything going on it it is
able to be fun even with the the weight
of everything it does those tones should
clash but they don't oh man another this
is another case of there's no way that's
gonna work oh they made it work number 5
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 quite
possibly the most emotionally
intelligent film on this list the way
that these characters have evolved in
our
growing or are resisting growing and the
journeys that they go on what we learn
about quill what he learns about himself
what we learned about yondu watching
these people try and come to terms with
themselves
with each other and ego is a is a great
was a great pick for a villain just
especially the more that that is
available the more you think about it on
every level the surface the meta the
subtext ah that was a terrific villain
pick and worked so so well this is just
like it's an emotionally brilliant film
is what it is it juggles such
complicated emotional arcs and journeys
and conflict for its characters and that
sort of things usually so token and
movies like that and this but it's not
here it's the core of it it's great
number four Captain America Winter
Soldier this used to be my number one
there are little nitpicky things about
it that I that I could point out but I
still think this is great I love the
shift in tone from the First Avenger
I love the chemistry between Steve and
Falcon it's and and just the mission
Steve obsession with getting Bucky back
and not quite getting it in this film
the way that the espionage plot plays
out this is a way better interpretation
of Hydra where they are this infection
and that you actually you can't defeat
cuz you can't even track it all down way
better than the generic faceless
soldiers yelling hail Hydra
all the to uh such an upgrade across the
but now Chris Evans the Steve Rogers is
as good as he always was but finally the
rest of the story elevated to meet how
good he was yes
number three black panther such a
phenomenally design filmed the the
afro-futurist aesthetic is incredible
to look at the performances are great
from the fun villain of Klaw to the
wonderful
complex villain of kill monger Cherie Oh
like so many amazing characters but also
a really strong a story for the lead
character in this because his is a
journey not just of coming into his
destiny and his power but of also
questioning that legacy that he just
inherited he becomes the king the ruler
of a kingdom and then goes through an
experience that makes him question the
way this kingdom has been ruled up to
this point and he has not had reason to
question that before and it's just done
so smartly bringing up super legitimate
valid points and concerns and it's
really really brilliantly done number
two
spider-man homecoming now look this is
one that I'm not sure I can justify from
a film 101 perspective the spider-man's
my favorite superhero and I think Tom
Holland gives my favorite performance as
spider-man which is funny because I tend
to not like teenage spider-man nearly as
much as more adult 25 to 35 spider-man
but he's really good in this and the
villain the vulture Michael Keaton is
amazing zendaya is great she's got
terrific chemistry
Ned is a wonderful character this
revision of Aunt May's terrific all the
changes here's what I really love all
the changes were really thought through
and smart to take a look carefully at
what was done and what was changed what
was done different from the norm nothing
was done arbitrarily it was all done
very carefully like and I feel like the
example of fiying of that is Flash
Thompson Flash Thompson has always been
a bully of Peter that's his main thing
now back when the character was
originally created he was a big jock cuz
that was your standard bully but that's
not what bullying is like in the 21st
century what is he now oh he's social
media savvy he's tech savvy he thinks
he's the DJ he's a different kind of
bully but he's still a bully he's a
modern-day bully for
modern day spider-man wonderfully done
captures everything I love about
spider-man but brings it into the now
and I just love the hell out of this
movie doesn't quite take number one
though because number one had to be for
me Captain America Civil War this just
has everything it has amazing action
set-pieces amazing emotional core really
believable arcs for the characters great
genuine clashes between them ones that
had been built up across the film's up
to this point reluctant battles great
epic scope and then you know having the
intelligence to go really big at the
airport but then get really down and
dirty impersonal at the climax when
Steve and Tony have to duke it out there
is so much emotional weight in that
fight it's insane
this for me is the best of the MCU
that's my ranking what's yours
or what do you think mine whatever your
thoughts are drop something on down in
the comments let's talk about it usual
stuff you know what it is like subscribe
I shared this around if you feel so
inclined I have a patreon if you feel
like supporting me and helping this
channel grow thank you very much for
your time you don't have to do any of
that stuff I mentioned if you really
don't want to because end of the day
you're the council and I just run the
meetings until next time this council
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]